Objects are more than just actions.
Yeah, a dog can bark and wag its
tail but it's more than just that.
What if your objects were your customer.
Your customers have public actions but
private thoughts.
They've rich histories based on who and
where they came from, and
when something goes
wrong they let you know.
Objects are no different.
In this lesson, you'll keep exploring
more features of objects in Ruby.
You'll get four aspects in particular.
You'll examine what an object's
public and private interfaces are and
learn more about how they can interact
with themselves and with other objects.
You'll learn how class methods and
class variables can help add even more
powerful features to your applications.
You'll discover how inheritance
allows classes to well, inherit
characteristics from other classes
saving you tons of code in the long run.
And lastly, you'll learn how to make
your objects throw descriptive and
meaningful errors and exceptions.
If someone's going to deal
with errors in your programs,
might as well make them helpful errors.
Let's dive right in.